beware this isn't a story about YouTube
High School this is a story about love
actually I'm Hugh Grant and love
actually is everywhere love actually is
actually love actually this video is
actually about Love Actually
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow I really love my time at YouTube
high school so far I'm learning so much
I hope I can make my father proud
all right
fangirls are cutting prepare the
handshake Wow that is so great that [ __ ]
are you talking about I I was just
commenting about you holding hands
that's really nice
why well I'm impressed this school must
be so progressive to not fall under the
social norms of a regular high school
that normally suppresses public
affection and intimacy between two
people of the same sex what are you
[ __ ] gay the [ __ ] are you talking
about yeah sorry I just assumed you were
a couple we're not gay
yeah we're not we're totally straight
but listen kid you're new here so I'm
gonna tell you we're just pretending
pretending yes
we're totally straight we just pretend
that we're a couple the way it's simple
well for some weird fucked-up reason
twelve-year-old girls
wants to see two straight males as a
couple this wasn't a thing before but
since all twelve-year-old girls are
ruled by hive mind and hi everyone says
straight males being gay is so super
popular right now we does what the hi
mind says we hold hands we meet up after
school we text each other and sometimes
we target rather off naked but we're not
I repeat not gay it's called shipping
you should get on board yes
shipping do you even have a ship name a
ship what ha a ship name I bet he
doesn't even know what that is
ha ha ha if you want to make it in here
you better find someone that will ship
you whale break oh you're gonna say
climb Titanic alright we gotta go okay I
didn't know about this
I must have missing it in my studies
teacher tell me more about shipping
listen no one [ __ ] understands
anything about this I don't understand
if people want to be gay then why can't
they just be gay why do they have to be
so [ __ ] gay about it teacher that's
super Hellmouth fobbing well you want
some all right oh [ __ ] I gotta go oh
well I better make my father proud
[Music]
[Music]
Hey sorry I'm busy studying oh that's
interesting maybe I could have no sorry
I'm better off oh this could be my
chance
fangirls are watching what do I do um
yeah you can help me study after school
perhaps want to get some coffee
sure I love coffee okay why don't you
give me your number and text me
[Music]
sure it's zero seven three nine four
five six nine six nine six nine four
then see their bet I bet have a dividend
he actually looks very pretty hey I
think I like potato potato it's red well
I sure hope that helps with your school
let me know if there's anything else I
can help you with see you later
he's so handsome
what is his feelings I keep thinking
about him
maybe I should text him
when I meet up and jerk each other off
nine folded stay where you are I'll be
right there but nothing gay or anything
okay
hashtag no homo no homo see ya there
oh my god I think I have feelings for
him I better tell him honestly but I
don't think he sees me the same way I
better tell him anyway this is my only
chance
all right be gentle with me I've only
done this with like five yeah they're
youtubers hey hey hey Peter Pan
yeah yes there's there's something I'm
gonna tell you you can you can I wait
please Jesus Christ okay then come on
our first my daddy I can't do this
anymore
[Music]
in the night in the morning in the day I
don't know how to tell you that up no
idea what the [ __ ] I'm doing
all I want to tell you burn in my group
it's time to tell you how I feel I
waited for this moment our secrets you
told me
but there is a detail told about
door
[Music]
I really wanted to say
if there's something manly here that
your memory
rub my eyes rub my absent
I scrub my
to tell you how I feel I waited for this
moment
see
[Music]
door
the
[Music]
maybe we'll always just be friends
maybe we'll get some faker friends the
same way you're not to be
[Music]
I shave their night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
friends
[Music]
be friends